Katrina: 够用吗
Katrina: Will it be enough?
Jake:那就买几个杯子
Jake: Then just buy a few cups.
Katrina: 好的收到
Katrina: Got it, roger that.
Tasha: 不是有一次性杯子吗
Tasha: Don't we have disposable cups?
Katrina: 他不给用
Katrina: He won't let us use them.
Katrina: 一次性杯子
Katrina: Disposable cups.
Shure: 就是不符合我们的理念你懂吗
Shure: It just doesn't fit our philosophy, you know?
Katrina: 好买呃
Katrina: Fine, buy them.
Jack: 严格follow Essex review的要求
Jack: Strictly follow Essex review's requirements.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure: Isaac是吧
Shure: Isaac, right?
Shure: 就Isaac绑架
Shure: Just Isaac kidnapping.
Jack: 我还是需要Isaac
Jack: I still need Isaac.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure: 那我就说你们囚禁volunteer好吧
Shure: Then I'll say you guys are imprisoning volunteers, alright?
Shure: 你们对
Shure: You guys...
Shure: 你们到时候发文章我就说你们foss
Shure: When you publish articles, I'll say you guys are FOSS.
Shure: 我的都是
Shure: Mine are all...
Shure: 拿
Shure: Take it.
Jack: 买汇源呗
Jack: Buy Huiyuan, right?
Jack: 哦对汇源没啥好的
Jack: Oh right, Huiyuan doesn't have anything good.
Choiszt: 那来个大的
Choiszt: Then get a big one.
Choiszt: 下边有大的
Choiszt: There's a big one down there.
Shure: 这不是一样
Shure: Isn't this the same?
Shure: 大的吗
Shure: The big one?
Choiszt: 哦不好意思
Choiszt: Oh, sorry.
Shure: 这就是视视觉错觉是吧
Shure: This is just a visual illusion, right?
Shure: 别没等那到那就脆了
Shure: Don't let it shatter before we even get there.
Shure: 这玩意放底下真的安全吗
Shure: Is it really safe to put this at the bottom?
Katrina: 不知道哇
Katrina: I don't know, wow.
Shure: 我感觉他绝对等不到我们结账就得碎
Shure: I feel like it definitely won't make it until we check out before it breaks.
Katrina: 买什么汁
Katrina: What juice to buy?
Katrina: 橙汁啊有桃汁了
Katrina: Orange juice, ah, there's peach juice.
Katrina: 太好了养乐多
Katrina: Great, Yakult.
Shure: 你不害怕吗
Shure: Aren't you scared?
Katrina: 再来一瓶西柚吧
Katrina: Let's get another grapefruit.
Katrina: 酒要买一瓶
Katrina: We need to buy a bottle of wine.
Shure: 要的
Shure: Got it.
Katrina: 全是饮料这
Katrina: It's all drinks here.
Katrina: 两天感觉就是摄入的有点那个
Katrina: Feels like we're consuming a bit much in two days.
Shure: 我这两天好像都没有喝矿泉水了都
Shure: I don't think I've had mineral water in the past two days.
Shure: 真不健康你
Shure: You're really unhealthy.
Shure: 啊好累啊
Shure: Ah, so tired.
Katrina: 你下午没睡觉吗
Katrina: Didn't you nap this afternoon?
Shure: 没睡一直在配环境嗯
Shure: No, I've been setting up the environment.
Katrina: 啊你一直在配环境
Katrina: Ah, you've been setting up the environment?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Shure: 咋了
Shure: What's up?
Shure: 不是你们会扒吗
Shure: Didn't you guys say you could peel it?
Shure: 不会
Shure: No?
Shure: 你买干什么
Shure: Then why did you buy it?
Jake:这多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Well,
Jake:这怎么吃
Jake: How do you eat this?
Shure: 这是三室的
Shure: This is the three-chamber one.
Shure: 这个啊四个应该是
Shure: This one should have four chambers.
Choiszt: 你要买一个熟一点
Choiszt: You should get a riper one.
Tasha: 我感觉这个这个不太好
Tasha: I feel like this one isn't very good.
Katrina: 什么叫三室
Katrina: What do you mean by three-chamber?
Shure: 就是三个瓣和四个瓣
Shure: It means three segments or four segments.
Shure: 就是拆开之后
Shure: When you open it up,
Shure: 你大概看他那个轮廓能看出来
Shure: you can kind of see the outline.
Katrina: 这能从外面看出来
Katrina: Can you tell from the outside?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Nicous: 新加坡榴莲不应该很便宜
Nicous: Aren't durians in Singapore supposed to be cheap?
Jake:就这些东西
Jake: Just these things,
Jake:我觉得随便买到这我觉得不划算
Jake: I don't think it's worth buying them here.
Shure: 哦我们上次是不是还买山竹来着
Shure: Oh, didn't we buy mangosteens last time?
Shure: 吃了吗
Shure: Did we eat them?
Shure: 我想吃我一直惦记这块
Shure: I want to eat them, I've been thinking about them.
Shure: 我山竹惦记好久啊
Shure: I've been craving mangosteens for a long time.
Shure: 特甜山竹
Shure: They're really sweet.
Shure: 你知道这
Shure: You know,
Shure: 这其实是东北特产的你知道吗
Shure: these are actually a specialty from Northeast China, did you know that?
Jake:但差不多也长这样
Jake: But they look similar.
Jake:我也吃不出来我也吃不出来
Jake: I can't tell the difference, I can't tell.
Jake:这样我就觉得
Jake: So I think...
Lucia: 对我也尝不出来
Lucia: Yeah, I can't tell either.
Jake:结论就是准备
Jake: The conclusion is to prepare...
Lucia: 小宁真的有吓到我
Lucia: Xiao Ning really scared me.
Lucia: 没想到
Lucia: I didn't expect that.
Shure: 青提每天买都每天吃是吧
Shure: Green grapes, you buy and eat them every day, right?
Katrina: 真好吃可以倒那个养乐多倒的
Katrina: They're really good, you can pour Yakult over them.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 养乐多和旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Yakult and Wang Zai milk.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 他这是打特价吗
Katrina: Is this on sale?
Katrina: 为什么这么大一盒才15块钱
Katrina: Why is such a big box only 15 yuan?
Shure: 因为那看着
Shure: Because it looks...
Shure: 你看跟这色都不一样
Shure: Look, this color is different.
Shure: 这还发绿那
Shure: This one even looks green.
Shure: 个太黄了
Shure: This one is too yellow.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 这是芋头吧
Shure: Is this taro?
Shure: 啊这是冬笋
Shure: Oh, this is bamboo shoot.
Shure: 对不起
Shure: Sorry.
Katrina: 哇这都能认错
Katrina: Wow, you can even mix that up?
Shure: 我不知道笋
Shure: I don't know bamboo shoots.
Shure: 我想吃咸鸭蛋
Shure: I want to eat salted duck eggs.
Katrina: 有没有那种一个一个拿呗
Katrina: Can we get them one by one?
Shure: 嗯我想吃咸鸭蛋
Shure: Yeah, I want to eat salted duck eggs.
Katrina: 咸鸭蛋是不是有单个卖的
Katrina: Do they sell salted duck eggs individually?
Katrina: 拿两个呗
Katrina: Grab two.
Katrina: 一两块钱不在话下
Katrina: One or two bucks, no big deal.
Katrina: 这个是不是
Katrina: Is this it?
Shure: 拿一盒
Shure: Get a box.
Shure: 哦熟的太好了
Shure: Oh, these are cooked, awesome.
Shure: 不用担心
Shure: No worries.
Shure: 我爱你嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟
Shure: I love you doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
Katrina: 还要买一瓶龙舌兰
Katrina: We also need to buy a bottle of tequila.
Shure: 小时候没有这种
Shure: We didn't have this when we were kids.
Katrina: 嗯我也喜欢玩
Katrina: Yeah, I also like to play.
Katrina: 你要买什么
Katrina: What do you want to buy?
Shure: 这都ADHD的症状哈哈哈
Shure: These are all symptoms of ADHD hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈杨老板直接拿一袋啊
Katrina: Hahaha, Jake just grabbed a whole bag.
Choiszt: 哈哈看着不是很新鲜
Choiszt: Haha, it doesn't look very fresh.
Katrina: 嗯哎今天晚上吃什么
Katrina: Yeah, what are we eating tonight?
Katrina: 不知道啊
Katrina: No idea.
Choiszt: 扔地上
Choiszt: Throw it on the ground.
Choiszt: 素质最大化
Choiszt: Maximize the quality.
Shure: 哈你看这就是老北京的地道咱说
Shure: Haha, see, this is the authentic Beijing style.
Choiszt: 咱们今天晚上吃啥
Choiszt: What are we eating tonight?
Shure: 今天晚上
Shure: Tonight...
Shure: 咱今天晚上外外卖吧外卖吧
Shure: Let's get takeout tonight, takeout.
Shure: 麦当劳吧
Shure: How about McDonald's?
Shure: 不至于吧
Shure: No way.
Shure: 现在才4:08
Shure: It's only 4:08.
Shure: 啊对你把牛排煎了吧
Shure: Oh yeah, you should fry the steak.
Choiszt: 这个糕点呢
Choiszt: What about this pastry?
Katrina: 是不是周黑鸭
Katrina: Is it Zhou Hei Ya?
Choiszt: 糕点有人吃吗
Choiszt: Anyone want pastries?
Shure: 草这不下酒啊
Shure: Dude, this doesn't go with alcohol.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Oh, man.
Shure: 这
Shure: This...
Jack: 好我们俩晚饭已经吃过了今天你们自己安排
Jack: Alright, we've already had dinner, you guys figure it out yourselves tonight.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Katrina: 吃方便面
Katrina: Let's eat instant noodles.
Katrina: 这拿来当早饭还是当明天的糕点
Katrina: Should we have this for breakfast or as tomorrow's pastry?
Katrina: 晚上的糕点
Katrina: Tonight's pastry.
Jake:晚上我们要做糕点
Jake: Tonight we're making pastries.
Jake:晚上我们要做很多很多
Jake: We're making lots and lots tonight.
Jake:很多很多
Jake: Lots and lots.
Katrina: 昨天做了麻薯
Katrina: We made mochi yesterday.
Shure: 那麻薯
Shure: That mochi...
Shure: 盒马的这种瑞士卷特别好吃
Shure: The Swiss rolls from Hema are really tasty.
Shure: 干什么呢
Shure: What are you doing?
Nicous: 别拍别拍
Nicous: Don't film, don't film.
Nicous: 拍不了一点
Nicous: You can't film at all.
Shure: 就我就一直盯着你的手
Shure: I'm just staring at your hand.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Nicous: 我小手很干净
Nicous: My hands are very clean.
Katrina: 去拿养乐多吧
Katrina: Go get some Yakult.
Shure: 哈哈惦记半天了快去吧
Shure: Haha, you've been thinking about it for so long, just go.
Shure: 我也是还有那个桑椹的
Shure: Me too, and that mulberry one.
Shure: 我特别喜欢吃
Shure: I really love eating it.
Katrina: 这是优益c
Katrina: This is Youyi C.
Katrina: 这不是养乐多
Katrina: This isn't Yakult.
Shure: 养乐多和UVC差不多吧
Shure: Yakult and UVC are pretty much the same, right?
Katrina: 拿两排吧
Katrina: Take two rows.
Katrina: 这边好像没有看到酒哎
Katrina: It seems like there's no alcohol here.
Shure: 楼下呢就跟这个
Shure: Downstairs, just like when we came in.
Shure: 咱俩进门的时候看到的
Shure: We saw it when we walked in.
Shure: 你说我都不懂
Shure: You know, I don't understand.
Shure: 那些baby
Shure: Those babies...
Shure: 不要冷漠我
Shure: Don't be cold to me.
Shure: 当我一
Shure: When I...
Shure: 外的旅程得到一些可以任性的机会
Shure: Go on an unexpected journey, I get some chances to be willful.
Shure: 让自己猜呀
Shure: Make myself guess.
Shure: 意外的女生
Shure: Unexpected girls...
Shure: 得到别人想要做的事
Shure: Getting what others want to do
Shure: 看似自由
Shure: Seems like freedom
Shure: 但是事上发生着
Shure: But in reality, things happen
Shure: 从来没想过真正想要的都被别人拿走
Shure: Never thought that what I truly want is taken by others
Shure: 没决定太多事就这样到底今天
Shure: Not deciding too many things, just like this until today
Jack: 我们现在只剩一辆
Jack: We only have one car left now
Katrina: 你们车呢
Katrina: Where's your car?
Jake:车丢了
Jake: The car is lost
Jack: 唉正好丢了
Jack: Oh, it just got lost
Jack: 有东西那个车健康的Pad还在里面
Jack: There's something, the health pad is still in that car
Jack: 哈哈哈丢了个Pad
Jack: Haha, lost a pad
Shure: 哈哈哈乐死了
Shure: Haha, that's hilarious
Shure: 车都车都不经过好了
Shure: The car, the car didn't even go through well
Lucia: 有道理
Lucia: Makes sense
Katrina: 哦买噶太皮了有点
Katrina: Oh my god, that's a bit too much
Katrina: 去找旺仔牛奶吧
Katrina: Let's go find some Wangzai milk
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Shure: 太离谱
Shure: That's outrageous
Katrina: 我们以前小学喝这个
Katrina: We used to drink this in elementary school
Katrina: 就学校给发这个
Katrina: The school used to give it out
Shure: 高钙奶
Shure: High calcium milk
Katrina: 一袋一袋的
Katrina: In small bags
Katrina: 杨梅汁
Katrina: Yangmei juice
Shure: 拿吧就哎呀反正
Shure: Just take it, anyway
Shure: 杨老板结账
Shure: Jake will pay
Shure: 真不拿白不拿啊
Shure: If you don't take it, it's a waste
Katrina: 没看见旺仔牛奶呀
Katrina: Didn't see any Wangzai milk
Shure: 这都录着呢我靠
Shure: This is all being recorded, oh my
Shure: 我把这卖了
Shure: I'll sell this
Choiszt: 采集数据需要
Choiszt: Need to collect data
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly
Katrina: 旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Wangzai milk
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Yeah, yeah
Katrina: 一楼饮料的
Katrina: On the first floor, drinks section
Nicous: 这个想吃了
Nicous: I want to eat this
Shure: 好嘞
Shure: Alright
Nicous: 那还能不吃
Nicous: How can I not eat it
Katrina: 非要我点头是吧
Katrina: You really need me to nod, huh
Shure: 我想吃吗
Shure: Do I want to eat it?
Shure: 我不想吃
Shure: I don't want to eat it
Nicous: 他想吃了
Nicous: He wants to eat.
Shure: 志愿者想吃吗你
Shure: Do you, as a volunteer, want to eat?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈这
Shure: Hahahaha
Shure: 不想
Shure: No, I don't.
Katrina: 嗯吃哈哈哈
Katrina: Yeah, eat hahaha
Choiszt: 你问问他哪个不吃
Choiszt: Ask him which one he doesn't want to eat.
Katrina: 这个不吃这奶味
Katrina: He doesn't want this one, it's milky.
Katrina: 不是高铁上推销呢
Katrina: It's not like we're selling stuff on the high-speed rail.
Katrina: 嗯我想吃青柠味的
Katrina: Hmm, I want the lime-flavored one.
Nicous: 这个青柠和黄瓜都可以
Nicous: Both the lime and cucumber flavors are fine.
Nicous: 嗯那就这个吧
Nicous: Hmm, then let's go with this one.
Shure: 一新币哎
Shure: One Singapore dollar, huh?
Shure: 哈哈你知道我不
Shure: Haha, you know I don't...
Shure: 咖啡不用了
Shure: No need for coffee.
Shure: 走走走
Shure: Let's go, let's go.
Nicous: 不是我现在感觉那个写的
Nicous: No, I feel like that shopping list...
Nicous: 那个购物清单没有意义啊
Nicous: That shopping list is meaningless.
Shure: 没有任何意义
Shure: Absolutely meaningless.
Nicous: 祝我永远的给你们激发灵感
Nicous: I hope I always inspire you guys.
Katrina: 公费吃喝
Katrina: Publicly funded eating and drinking.
Katrina: 那我想想我还有什么想吃的
Katrina: Let me think about what else I want to eat.
Shure: 找着了吗
Shure: Have you found it?
Shure: 这是啥呀
Shure: What is this?
Lucia: 西梅
Lucia: Prunes.
Shure: 试吃的吗
Shure: Is it for tasting?
Lucia: 是啊啊不是
Lucia: Yes, no.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina: 我们这是把那个to do list都完成了
Katrina: We've completed the to-do list.
Shure: 你们快完成to do list
Shure: You guys are almost done with the to-do list.
Shure: 我们这都完成了
Shure: We're all done here.
Jake:你们to do完了
Jake: Are you guys done with the to-do list?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 这是to do list上吗
Lucia: Is this on the to-do list?
Shure: 差不多没有啊
Shure: Almost, not really.
Shure: 哎呀这自由发挥
Shure: Oh, this is a bit of free play.
Choiszt: 你的两车不太够吃
Choiszt: Your two carts aren't enough food.
Jake:哈哈哈这个人也挺自由啊
Jake: Haha, this person is quite free.
Jake:哈哈哈还有吗
Jake: Hahaha, is there more?
Jake:那这些是干嘛的
Jake: What are these for?
Katrina: 这是小食
Katrina: These are snacks.
Shure: 这些这也是给嘉宾
Shure: These are for the guests.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Just
Jake:哎行行行走吧
Jake: Alright, alright, let's go.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 怕嘉宾们吃
Shure: Afraid the guests will eat
Shure: 因为中中国有句古话叫有朋自远方来
Shure: Because there's an old Chinese saying, "A friend from afar."
Shure: 不亦乐乎
Shure: Is that not joyous?
其他人：虽远必诛
Others: Even if far, must be punished.
Katrina: 哈哈哈你有几个朋友
Katrina: Hahaha, how many friends do you have?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Nicous: 你没看过那个阿巴斯的评论区吗
Nicous: Haven't you seen Abas's comment section?
Lucia: 这是一那种新新的弱智吧吗
Lucia: Is this a new kind of idiot?
Nicous: 我操我给你看一下
Nicous: Damn, let me show you.
Jake:什么呀
Jake: What is it?
Nicous: 你竟然没看过阿巴斯
Nicous: You haven't seen Abas?
Katrina: 下一楼
Katrina: Next floor.
Shure: 我们还有啥没买
Shure: What else haven't we bought?
Shure: 其实有啥没买都可以外卖买
Shure: Actually, anything we missed, we can just order takeout.
Katrina: 旺旺仔牛奶跟龙舌兰
Katrina: Wangwang milk and tequila.
Lucia: 神经病哈哈哈
Lucia: Crazy hahaha.
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What's that?
Nicous: 谁看过阿拉巴斯
Nicous: Who has seen Alabas?
Lucia: 如果你来我家的话我会请你吃闭门羹
Lucia: If you come to my house, I'll treat you with a closed door.
Katrina: 哦哦哦我看过这个
Katrina: Oh, I've seen this.
Katrina: 就是一个外国人
Katrina: It's a foreigner.
Katrina: 然后大家都在他评论区里说一些中文
Katrina: And everyone says some scrambled Chinese in his comments.
Katrina: 语法颠倒的那种乱七八糟的
Katrina: Like messed up grammar and stuff.
Jake:他在学中文是吧
Jake: He's learning Chinese, right?
Katrina: 去一楼不
Katrina: Go to the first floor?
Katrina: 哦一楼
Katrina: Oh, first floor.
Katrina: 从那下
Katrina: Down there.
Katrina: 我看到有一个人头慢慢的下去
Katrina: I saw someone's head slowly going down.
Shure: 人头在什么啊啊
Shure: Head in what, huh?
Nicous: 阿巴斯你记住是金子总会发光
Nicous: Abas, remember, gold always shines.
Shure: 总在发光
Shure: Always shining.
Nicous: 但是你是老铁
Nicous: But you're iron.
Shure: 老铁
Shure: Iron.
Nicous: 阿巴斯景色无端
Nicous: Abas, scenery without end.
Nicous: 50钱那景色有多少钱哈哈
Nicous: How much does fifty money's scenery cost, haha?
Shure: 50
Shure: Fifty.
Shure: 还是25的人
Shure: Still a 25-year-old.
Shure: 今天教资不考人
Shure: No one's taking the teacher qualification test today.
Nicous: 你可以享受原价
Nicous: You can enjoy the original price.
Nicous: 阿巴我操
Nicous: Oh my god, what the heck.
Nicous: 这个是最逆天的
Nicous: This is the most incredible.
Nicous: 阿巴斯你记住
Nicous: Abbas, remember this.
Nicous: 太空有太空
Nicous: Space has space.
Nicous: 太空有空间站
Nicous: There's a space station in space.
Nicous: 太挤就没有空间站
Nicous: If it's too crowded, there's no space station.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Shure: 啊啊我靠牛逼
Shure: Ah, wow, this is awesome.
Katrina: 我就说看到有人头缓缓的下去
Katrina: I just saw someone's head slowly going down.
Katrina: 哈哈我同学crush crush
Katrina: Haha, my classmate has a crush, crush.
Shure: 那个红衣服是你同学crush
Shure: That person in red is your classmate's crush?
Shure: 是吗啊
Shure: Really?
Katrina: 他跟人家用情头呢
Katrina: They're using couple profile pictures.
Nicous: 这个吗
Nicous: This one?
Katrina: 开他玩笑
Katrina: Just kidding.
Katrina: 他
Katrina: He...
Katrina: 嗯他俩认识很久了
Katrina: Uh, they've known each other for a long time.
Katrina: 然后他妈就跟他说
Katrina: Then his mom told him,
Katrina: 你你俩要不在一起得了
Katrina: "Why don't you two just be together?"
Katrina: 就是这个女生从来不找男朋友嘛
Katrina: Because this girl never finds a boyfriend.
Katrina: 谁又喜欢
Katrina: Who would like...
Katrina: 这倒长得挺帅哈
Katrina: This guy is actually pretty handsome, huh?
Shure: 是啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 这把华科去了
Katrina: He went to Huake University.
Nicous: 你冲他
Nicous: You should go for him.
Katrina: 我靠他从南航到华科
Katrina: Wow, he transferred from Nanhang to Huake.
Katrina: 我从武理里到东南
Katrina: I transferred from Wuli to Dongnan.
Katrina: 咱俩交换地狱呢
Katrina: We're exchanging hells.
Nicous: 这就是缘分
Nicous: That's fate.
Shure: 缘分让我们
Shure: Fate brought us together.
Shure: 相遇乱世以外
Shure: Outside this chaotic world.
Katrina: 你知道当时我同
Katrina: You know, back then my classmate...
Katrina: 我是我同学
Katrina: I mean, my classmate...
Katrina: 就是说要介绍我俩认识
Katrina: Said they wanted to introduce us.
Katrina: 那男的看
Katrina: That guy saw...
Katrina: 我朋友圈说我太潮了
Katrina: My social media and said I'm too trendy.
Katrina: 高攀不起
Katrina: Out of his league.
Shure: 他风湿病犯了是吗
Shure: Is his rheumatism acting up?
Katrina: 不知道啊
Katrina: No idea.
Katrina: 我哪潮了
Katrina: How am I trendy?
Katrina: 我想请问
Katrina: I want to ask,
Katrina: 他线下见我以后
Katrina: after he met me offline,
Katrina: 就觉得不会觉得我是潮人了
Katrina: he doesn't think I'm trendy anymore.
Shure: 粉毛染的吧
Shure: You dyed your hair pink, right?
Katrina: 可能吧粉毛吓着人家了
Katrina: Maybe, the pink hair scared him.
Shure: 那你给人家吓死了
Shure: You scared him to death.
Katrina: 乖乖男一枚啊
Katrina: I'm a good boy.
Shure: 妈妈不让我带
Shure: My mom won't let me date
Shure: 找染头发并且有纹身的女生
Shure: girls who dye their hair and have tattoos.
Katrina: 咦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 确定这会有龙舌兰吗
Katrina: Are you sure they have tequila here?
Shure: 有吧
Shure: They should.
Katrina: 旺仔和龙舌兰
Katrina: Wangzai and tequila?
Katrina: 这会有龙舌兰吗
Katrina: Do they have tequila here?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Shure: 他这没有龙舌兰
Shure: They don't have tequila here.
Shure: 他傻没了
Shure: He's so dumb.
Shure: 这全是这种气泡酒的
Shure: It's all sparkling wine here.
Katrina: 白兰地是什么酒
Katrina: What kind of drink is brandy?
Katrina: 难道
Katrina: Could it be...
Shure: 没了
Shure: It's gone.
Shure: 完了那一会外卖吧
Shure: We'll just order takeout later.
Shure: 木油啊
Shure: There's no oil.
Choiszt: 这超市有点太小
Choiszt: This supermarket is too small.
Shure: 是的怪不得怪不得
Shure: Yeah, no wonder, no wonder.
Shure: 帅总进来先
Shure: Choiszt, come in first.
Shure: 这超市档次不够
Shure: This supermarket isn't high-end enough.
Shure: 没有啊
Shure: There's nothing here.
Katrina: 没有那就点外卖吧
Katrina: There's nothing, let's order takeout.
Shure: 点外卖呗
Shure: Let's order takeout.
Shure: 然后还可以二锅头兑那什么
Shure: And then we can mix Erguotou with something.
Shure: 兑那个西柚汁
Shure: Mix it with grapefruit juice.
Shure: 一喝一个蒙
Shure: One sip and you're out.
Katrina: 这个称了吗
Katrina: Did we weigh this?
Shure: 没西
Shure: No, we didn't.
Jack: 一楼称
Jack: Weigh it on the first floor.
Jack: 这个一楼称吗
Jack: Do we weigh this on the first floor?
Lucia: 他说结账的那个称
Lucia: He said the scale at the checkout.
Shure: 啊我好困
Shure: Ah, I'm so sleepy.
Jack: 两瓶两个车形成鲜明的对比
Jack: Two bottles and two cars make a sharp contrast.
Nicous: 我觉得这个这么多东西三个人吃
Nicous: I think this much food is for three people.
Nicous: 三个人就吃完了
Nicous: Three people will finish it.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Jack: 那建议你速速找
Jack: Then I suggest you find it quickly.
Jack: 健康要方便
Jack: Health should be convenient.
Nicous: 这是买给嘉宾吃的吗
Nicous: Is this for the guests to eat?
Nicous: 不可能啊
Nicous: No way.
Nicous: 这个东西很很危害健康啊
Nicous: This stuff is really bad for health.
Nicous: 吃吃瓜子会上火
Nicous: Eating too many sunflower seeds causes internal heat.
Shure: 话筒明天他们从北邮带
Shure: They'll bring the microphone from Beiyou tomorrow.
Katrina: 哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh.
Shure: 让我带你去
Shure: Let me take you there.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Choiszt: 修硕你那个咸鸭蛋
Choiszt: Shure, the salted duck egg.
Choiszt: 要什么情景下吃
Choiszt: When are you going to eat it?
Shure: 今天晚上吃
Shure: Tonight.
Choiszt: 干吃
Choiszt: Plain?
Shure: 就着汉堡好吃
Shure: It's good with a burger.
Jack: 咸鸭蛋配汉堡
Jack: Salted duck egg with a burger?
Jack: 中西结合
Jack: East meets West.
Shure: 好这一口
Shure: Yeah, this bite.
Shure: 想太久了你
Shure: You've been thinking too long.
Shure: 今天中午吃的卤煮
Shure: Had braised pork for lunch today.
Shure: 但那卤煮不行
Shure: But that braised pork wasn't good.
Shure: 不地道
Shure: Not authentic.
Nicous: 你们都吃卤煮
Nicous: You all had braised pork?
Shure: 差不多吧
Shure: Pretty much.
Jack: 我好奇刘帅
Jack: I'm curious, Choiszt.
Jack: 你是北京人
Jack: Are you from Beijing?
Jack: 你能喝豆汁吗
Jack: Can you drink douzhi (fermented mung bean milk)?
Choiszt: 不喝不是
Choiszt: No, I can't.
Choiszt: 我都没怎么吃过那个北京小吃
Choiszt: I haven't really had those Beijing snacks.
Jack: 真的吗你从小到大都没吃过
Jack: Really? You've never had them since you were a kid?
Choiszt: 那都是人家老北
Choiszt: That's for the old Beijingers.
Choiszt: 那些老北京人
Choiszt: Those old Beijing folks.
Shure: 你家哪区的
Shure: Which district are you from?
Choiszt: 就海淀区
Choiszt: Just in Haidian District.
Choiszt: 哎这小瓶刚买了俩大瓶
Choiszt: Hey, this small bottle just bought two big bottles.
Jake:对就是这个
Jake: Yeah, this is it.
Jake:稍微便宜
Jake: It's a bit cheaper.
Shure: 我天啊
Shure: Oh my god.
Jake:能便宜个一毛半
Jake: It’s cheaper by one and a half cents.
Shure: 一毛半新币人民币哈哈哈
Shure: One and a half cents in New Currency, RMB, hahaha.
Choiszt: 为了这一毛半
Choiszt: For that one and a half cents.
Choiszt: 然后在这纠结
Choiszt: And you're hesitating here.
Choiszt: 然后买了好多额外的
Choiszt: And bought a lot of extra stuff.
Nicous: 这个和这个放在一起我有点于心不忍
Nicous: Putting this and this together, I feel a bit guilty.
Tasha: 为什么
Tasha: Why?
Shure: 哎呀哈哈哈
Shure: Aiya hahaha.
Shure: 都是meta付
Shure: They are all meta payments.
Shure: 不是吗
Shure: Aren’t they?
Shure: 是不是咱们开发票
Shure: If we invoice.
Shure: 开什么脸书有限公司是吗
Shure: Should we invoice as Facebook Co., Ltd.?
Jack: 我们只能开
Jack: We can only issue.
Jack: 感觉时间有限
Jack: It feels like time is limited.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is it?
Shure: 我我们我们我们
Shure: We, we, we.
Shure: 我们开发票的话应该开什么
Shure: If we invoice, what should we issue it for?
Katrina: 走吧
Katrina: Let’s go.
Jake:走吧
Jake: Let’s go.
Shure: 其实咱们都能开
Shure: Actually, we can issue it.
Shure: 但是国外报销他走发票这一套吗
Shure: But does foreign reimbursement follow the invoice process?
Shure: 都不走是吧
Shure: They don't follow it, right?
Shure: 那走什么
Shure: Then what do they follow?
Shure: 信任
Shure: Trust.
Shure: 真的呀
Shure: Really?
Jake:走走预算报账啊
Jake: They follow the budget reimbursement process.
Lucia: 说到这个既然快递都到的差不多了
Lucia: Speaking of which, now that most of the deliveries have arrived.
Lucia: 可以报销一下吗
Lucia: Can we get reimbursed?
Jake:可以啊可以
Jake: Yes, we can.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 那我怎么发呀
Lucia: How should I send it?
Jake:我我回头弄Excel
Jake: I’ll create an Excel sheet later.
Tasha: 我要弄吗
Tasha: Should I do it?
Tasha: 哎都大家都要弄Excel
Tasha: Hey, everyone needs to do an Excel sheet.
Shure: 不是他他弄一个然后共享咱们贴就行
Shure: No, he’ll make one and then share it, we just need to paste it in.
Jake:干过啊
Jake: I've done it before.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:一次要干过是吧
Jake: You've done it once, right?
Shure: 肯定干过呀
Shure: Definitely done it.
Nicous: 有点破防了啊
Nicous: Kind of hit a nerve there.
Shure: 那确实
Shure: Indeed.
Jake:你懂吗你懂吗你懂吗
Jake: Do you understand? Do you get it?
Shure: 我懂啊我懂
Shure: Yeah, I get it.
Nicous: 你可能还不太懂
Nicous: Maybe you don't fully get it yet.
Jake:哈哈哈可能下个月让你懂一懂
Jake: Haha, maybe next month you'll understand.
Lucia: 哈哈我们要不要来一份
Lucia: Haha, should we get some?
Lucia: 请嘉宾喝茶
Lucia: Invite the guests for tea.
Jake:多少钱
Jake: How much?
Lucia: 319
Lucia: 319.
Shure: 60新币而已
Shure: Only 60 Singapore dollars.
Lucia: 但是他们家茶真的很好
Lucia: But their tea is really good.
Lucia: 这应该是一个北京老字号
Lucia: This should be an old Beijing brand.
Jack: 子伟有句名言
Jack: Ziwei has a famous saying.
Jack: 回到中国
Jack: Back in China,
Jack: 什么东西一除五就感觉没有那么贵了
Jack: Everything feels cheaper when divided by five.
Shure: 确实这谁的线掉了
Shure: True. Whose wire got disconnected?
Lucia: 他再多待几天回新加坡时候就该乘5
Lucia: If he stays a few more days, he'll multiply by five when he goes back to Singapore.
Shure: Lucy啊你的你的
Shure: Lucia, your, your...
Shure: 你的生命线
Shure: Your lifeline.
Lucia: 我给眼镜续个命吧
Lucia: Let me extend my glasses' life.
Lucia: 他现在没灭吧
Lucia: They aren't dead yet, right?
Shure: 有些酒没有买到
Shure: We didn't get some of the alcohol.
Shure: 还需要外卖购入一点有些不齐的酒
Shure: Need to order some more alcohol delivery, some are missing.
Shure: 就所有的酒都没有买到
Shure: We didn't get all the alcohol.
Jake:那就买吧
Jake: Then let's buy it.
Jake:要不现在就买吧
Jake: How about buying it now?
Shure: 也也行回去再买也行不急
Shure: We could, or we could buy it later, no rush.
Lucia: 哎这里面还有一个充电宝
Lucia: Hey, there's a power bank in here.
Tasha: its me
Tasha: It's me.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Alright.
Jake:要不也插上生命线
Jake: How about plugging in the lifeline too?
Tasha: 哎那个人招手让我们过去吗
Tasha: Hey, is that person waving us over?
Shure: 啊好好好
Shure: Ah, okay, okay.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 你们怎么分开的啊
Shure: How did you guys get separated?
Shure: 啊一起的
Shure: Ah, together.
Shure: 我们是
Shure: We are...
Shure: 那也行吧
Shure: That works too.
Shure: 这样走吧
Shure: Let's go this way.
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
Shure: 袋子要要要
Shure: Need the bag, need it.
Jack: 那李子怎么办
Jack: What about the plums?
Shure: 这西梅
Shure: These are prunes.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 但是他俩英文翻译好都是一个
Shure: But both their English translations are the same.
Shure: 这叫POM好像
Shure: I think this is called POM.
Jack: 看起来没多少东西
Jack: Doesn't look like much.
Jack: 就300块钱
Jack: Just 300 bucks.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 这边我先付垫付了一下
Shure: I paid for this first.
Shure: 那西梅没个模什么的吗
Shure: Don't prunes have some mold or something?
Jake:这个这个
Jake: This one, this one.
Jack: 先先推车把这车推着吧
Jack: First, push the cart, let's push this cart.
Jake:再专门给他弄一个
Jake: Make a special one for him.
Shure: 封不了口好
Shure: Can't seal it well.
Shure: 哎这封不了口真离谱
Shure: Hey, this can't seal properly, it's ridiculous.
Jack: 好
Jack: Okay.
Jack: 你好你好
Jack: Hello, hello.
Nicous: 阿巴斯你要记住
Nicous: Abbas, you need to remember.
Nicous: 在中国干也好爱也好
Nicous: Whether you're working or loving in China.
Nicous: 人要是行干一行
Nicous: If you're capable, you can do any job.
Shure: 一行行行行行
Shure: Any job, job, job, job.
Nicous: 要是不行
Nicous: If you're not capable...
Shure: 干也好不行也好一行不行行行不行
Shure: Whether you work or not, you can't do any job, job, job.
Nicous: 他已经不回复
Nicous: He doesn't reply anymore.
Nicous: 这一行应该是没学会
Nicous: He probably hasn't mastered this job.
Shure: 他应该已经学完了
Shure: He probably already finished learning.
Nicous: 你真是很美好的一坨
Nicous: You really are a beautiful lump.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 哇你聪明哎啊哈哈
Shure: Wow, you're smart, huh, haha.
Shure: 我是个沉默不语的哒哒哒
Shure: I'm a silent dada dada.
Shure: 天干物燥
Shure: Dry weather.
Shure: 妖精火烛人
Shure: Goblin fire.
Shure: 生漫长是凶邪
Shure: Birth is long and evil.
Shure: 好身手
Shure: Great skill.
Shure: 爱过迈步
Shure: Love takes a step forward.
Shure: 走路就踮起来
Shure: Walk on your tiptoes.
Shure: 什么都不变
Shure: Nothing changes.
Shure: 风一直在高处不胜言
Shure: The wind is always high, hard to describe.
Shure: 你的眼神在烦恼的交
Shure: Your eyes are caught in worries.
Shure: 干杯
Shure: Cheers.
Jake:全给你们说
Jake: I'll tell you everything.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 这两个东西你们是不是要拿拿拿出去
Shure: Are you taking these two things out?
Lucia: 什么杯子
Lucia: Which cups?
Shure: 不是这两个拿出去
Shure: No, take these two out.
Shure: OK车就不用拿了
Shure: Okay, you don't need to take the car.
Shure: 就放这吧
Shure: Just leave it here.
Shure: 再见
Shure: Goodbye.
Jake:拜拜
Jake: Bye.
Katrina: 还有两个杯子在哪
Katrina: Where are the other two cups?
Nicous: 都在这里面
Nicous: They're all in here.
Nicous: 那里
Nicous: There.
Shure: 上车把这个关掉
Shure: Get in the car and turn this off.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina: 有味道吗
Katrina: Does it smell?
Choiszt: 哎他们那个烤箱
Choiszt: Hey, their oven...
Nicous: 还有一个杯子呢
Nicous: Where's the other cup?
Choiszt: 不管
Choiszt: Never mind.
Katrina: 轻点就行
Katrina: Just be gentle.
Choiszt: 这菠萝怎么感觉坏了
Choiszt: Why does this pineapple seem spoiled?
Shure: 因为菠萝菠萝蜜
Shure: Because pineapple, pineapple...
Shure: 菠萝蜜菠萝菠萝蜜
Shure: Pineapple, pineapple...
Katrina: 带我去带我去
Katrina: Take me there, take me there.
Shure: 没什么东西
Shure: There's nothing much.
Shure: 大米
Shure: Rice.
Nicous: 这是之前美团
Nicous: This is from Meituan before.
Nicous: 美团改小象超市改名
Nicous: Meituan changed to Xiaoxiang Supermarket.
Nicous: 改名成美团的时候送的东西
Nicous: When they changed to Meituan, they gave us these.
Choiszt: 是吗
Choiszt: Really?
Nicous: 哦这不是美团超市改成小象超市
Nicous: Oh, it wasn't Meituan Supermarket, it was Xiaoxiang Supermarket.
Nicous: 送的吗
Nicous: They gave us these.
Choiszt: 哪个右边
Choiszt: Which one, on the right?
Nicous: 就这个大的
Nicous: This big one.
Nicous: 就这个篓
Nicous: Just this basket.
Choiszt: 小心一点
Choiszt: Be careful.
Shure: 这个柴是吧
Shure: This firewood, right?
Nicous: 想吃什么
Nicous: What do you want to eat?
Katrina: 你拿着吃吧
Katrina: You eat it.
Katrina: 哎我想吃那个
Katrina: Oh, I want to eat that one.
Nicous: 你想吃巧克力是吧
Nicous: You want to eat chocolate, right?
Katrina: 我想吃我想吃
Katrina: I want to eat, I want to eat.
Choiszt: 你先把眼镜关掉
Choiszt: Turn off your glasses first.
Choiszt: 然后想拿什么
Choiszt: Then decide what to take.
Shure: 你刚刚没关
Shure: You didn't turn it off just now.
Shure: 你放回去
Shure: Put it back.
Shure: 你拿这个干什么呀
Shure: What are you taking this for?
Shure: 谢冰竹不
Shure: Are you thanking Bingzhu?
Katrina: 哎不好意思
Katrina: Oh, sorry.
Choiszt: 行了行了
Choiszt: Alright, alright.
Nicous: 不好意思
Nicous: Sorry.
Shure: 这杯子放这吗
Shure: Should I put this cup here?
Katrina: 拿着吧
Katrina: Just hold it.
Shure: 拿着吧
Shure: Just hold it.
Katrina: 拿吧我俩不看你
Katrina: Hold it, we won't look at you.
Katrina: 我不吃不吃你吃吧
Katrina: I won't eat, you eat it.
Shure: 谢冰竹你干什么呢
Shure: Bingzhu, what are you doing?
Shure: 谢冰竹拍的一清二楚
Shure: Bingzhu captured everything clearly.
Shure: 阿里嘎多
Shure: Arigato.
Katrina: 我给你开门
Katrina: I'll open the door for you.
Shure: 是的你不得还得扶着吗
Shure: Yes, you still have to hold it, right?
Shure: 服务真不到位
Shure: The service is really not up to par.
Shure: 怎么没学全套呢
Shure: How come you didn't learn the whole set?
Katrina: 所以被开了呀
Katrina: So I got fired.
Shure: 哎呦谁不开你啊
Shure: Oh, who would fire you?
Shure: 就你这样
Shure: With you like this...
Katrina: 带我去带我去
Katrina: Take me, take me.
Nicous: 吃吗
Nicous: Want some?
Katrina: 我要吃一个
Katrina: I want to eat one.
Shure: 啥呀我不吃我不吃
Shure: What? I won't eat, I won't eat.